we have up here two Academy Award
nominees a Tony winner so I'm going to
start with the new guy
Jonathan smear who wrote the screenplay
he was a corporate lawyer in London he
was a school teacher in South Korea how
the heck did this happen
so it's a very good question actually I
was a corporate lawyer for just as long
as I needed to be in order to pay off my
college debts whereupon I ran for the
exit to pursue a career in screenwriting
mainly because I love movies and I was
reasonably okay with words I thought so
I taught English at a university in
China for a year just to keep a roof
over my head while I taught myself the
basics of screenwriting
after a year in China I moved to South
Korea and it was there that I saw a TV
news interview with a guy I had never
heard of before by the name of Jack
Abramoff I'm sure you're all familiar
with him by the end of the interview I
was kind of glued to the screen thinking
what an interesting world in which to
set a screenplay so that was the genesis
of the idea and it was in South Korea
that I conceived and planned and wrote
Miss Sloan in South Korea that I got my
representation while working at a
Elementary School took a lot of general
meetings over Skype from my classroom
with little Korean eight-year-olds
waving in the background and it all got
photobombed in your kind I did by a
posse of Korean kids yeah and it all
happened while I was in South Korea all
the way up until August 2015
when I finally Tim I agree and had to
quit and focus on this full-time but
interestingly enough kind of before I
met my representatives or my agents or
anyone from film nation who optioned the
script the first person I met in
connection with any of this industry
this world was the man to my right john
madden whose hand i grasped in london
one day you have the screenplay in the
other hand III didn't he had it on the
table in front of him I think open on
his laptop and you know when I finally
shook them
and it was at that point that I realized
that this isn't a paranoid delusion it's
actually happening so in a nutshell
there you have it john madden so he
didn't stock you with the screenplay how
did it come to you it came you know it
dropped into my inbox from via film
nation via my agent who I think film
nation had approached and said which of
your directors do you think might be
interested in this anyway I read it you
know it's an extraordinary feat of
imagination the film I sorry the script
which is nevertheless not an imaginary
world although there are imaginary
elements to it the fact that the piece
of legislation gets passed puts it in
the realm of fantasy I think but but
there are many ways in which you know it
was both an extraordinary story very
very well told about extremely
interesting and contentious issues units
obviously about the paradox of why this
intractable issue persists in which most
of the country believe something should
be done about access to weapons but
nothing ever does get done in the
legislative process we expected that to
be an issue in the film we didn't expect
other aspects of the film to become such
an issue which is the political process
itself and particularly the idea of
women in politics that has become
bizarrely appropriate in terms of the
film's release but the chief reason that
I was attracted to the script was just
an extraordinary character study and in
a sort of perfect piece of synchronicity
within the first few pages I thought of
one person for this role which is not
quite as opportunistic as it sounds
because she and I been trading material
since film we made earlier together
called the debt when Jessica was not
well known at all
and Anna just you know movie that
screamed to be made and Johnny and I
this handshake that I'm now back at
started working on it together for six
months to bring it into the form that it
now is and Jessica Chastain lobbyists
ranked even below politicians when it
comes to a lot of public rankings so how
did you prepare a character who
intrinsically seemed unlikable but you
know you had to keep the audience
rooting for you somehow I always start
with a lot of research I start with the
script for me the script is everything I
find all the clues that I can use for
the character it helps you not play the
same character over and over again in
mini movies I read jack abramoff book
actually not even being told to or that
it was an inspiration for the script I
found out how much money was in lobbying
which was shocking to me I talked to
production about working with a lobbyist
and and they had hired someone and and I
met with him and I also I was really
important for me to meet with female
lobbyists because less than 10 percent
of lobbyists are women in DC and I
wanted to understand that dynamic so I
just like did I just googled and found
in a list of the most powerful female
obvious in DC I called their offices and
their assistants kind of thought it was
a joke or some kind of hoax and and then
I showed up one weekend and met with 11
women all of my stereotypes of what a
lobbyists were just blown out the window
seven of the eleven women had black nail
polish on which to me I was so shocked
by I thought I'd wear no makeup in this
movie and just you know be this dogged
all work person and then I realized how
these women had to present themselves in
the world it was their armor their suit
their battle cry they had to send the
energy into the room before they arrived
and that was very useful to me and also
we talked about drugs in DC and personal
lives and all that stuff so I have never
said the names of the people that I've
met with just because it was such an
honest
open conversation I wouldn't want to to
know that I blow my sources out of the
water very journalistic of you to
protect your sources John Lithgow you
had to play a senator who you know he
shifted during the course of the film
back and forth and back and forth and
yet you had to keep a core that would
also keep us interested and keep us not
entirely hating this man in fact on his
side and feeling sorry for himself at
some point how did you do that I does
this a mime it yes I can be heard all
right
I just thought of myself as a senator
and anybody in particular come to mind
not really Patrick Leahy had those
little glasses he's pretty much the only
person I didn't have time to think of
anything I was jumping off another
enormous project and virtually I got an
email from John like the last week I was
working on an 8 month long project in
England and just I think in within weeks
I was in Toronto playing this senator so
what I found fascinating with him about
him was he would be one of my senators
he would have been one of the guys I
voted for and on all on the same side as
me on all kinds of issues but you see
him capitulate to pressure which is the
most interesting and realistic thing
about Washington and about politics in
general certainly in this country is
that pressures are constantly on you and
those pressures have a lot to do with
money this of course made him a very
very interesting character to play I
read the script and it completely blew
my mind it was such a brilliant piece of
storytelling the fact that you learn
Sperling's secrets as you are learning
the secrets of the entire plot and yet
you've been watching him all this time
in the present time where all the events
of the past are brought to bear on
what's actually happening and it all
collides together at the moment
I ended the he the last thing he expects
is to be exposed in public these are
just wonderful things to hang on to for
an actor I Serb didn't need to do any
research besides which I've played three
or four senators before I was pre
researched so you have tenure yes sir I
haven't been voted out of office and
Jessica Chastain as with Oh dark thirty
you play a driven character who is
driven among men who all think they know
better so how did you strike the balance
in this one uh well in zero dark thirty
the character was so anti political
there was something almost immature
about her where she would just cut
people down and doesn't care who her
bosses and just you know she was almost
like a teenager and uh Elizabeth she's
she's very fluid with the way she can
manipulate she's almost seductive and I
needed to know it was more of a strategy
where she had to always figure out how
to get someone on her side I mean it
could be in terms of being a mentor it
could be in terms of intimidation it
could be flirting like she does with the
senator and that fundraiser there's uh
you know she has many masks this
character that she uses to her benefit
and John let's go your character in
particular finds that he has to
compromise in order to achieve the right
thing whether his selfish motives are
one thing but he believes in the
political process evidently we're seeing
this in real time in the elections right
now so so did you approach it as someone
who understands the American voter the
American voting process or was it just a
character that you plucked out of your
own ether to make the senator work well
I think that's a pretty accurate
description plucking it out of the ether
but it's so much of it was right there
in the script
he I think he just didn't he
he knew he had to go through this or he
would he would be voted out of office he
couldn't face just the power of money
the onslaught of money paid to unseat
him so we went ahead with this and just
hoped he would get through it he would
somehow discredit this woman without
doing too much damage to her and without
it going too far and then it goes
further and further and further because
nothing works to me it's it's it's
appalling to him that he has to resort
to his last couple of stratagems he
never wanted this rentboy to sit at a
desk in a Senate hearing room and dredge
all this garbage up in front of the
public he never wanted this to happen he
didn't want to be the engine for this
and yet he had to and not even that
worked so that little moment of disgust
is my favorite moment in the performance
you know it's it's just superb moral
dilemmas and everybody in the in the
script has them everyone has to make
choices and it's incredibly hard to make
right choices in such an atmosphere that
was my approach won't you please thank
our panel